Cada uno tenía que estar con su...
con su...
para poquito comida.
Después de las seis, ya la cocina cerrada.
Entonces era como el...
Seis horas de la noche y seis horas de la noche.
Ya.
Y en la mañana...
Veinte, como yo dormía en un piso concreto.
¿Con cuánta gente? ¿Cuánta gente había en ese piso?
Nosotros dos.
¿Solos? ¿Durmieron solos?
Sí, separados.
Allá era mínimo mi cárculo, ¿no? Mi cárculo.
Era con más de seis mil personas.
¿Y eran casitas pequeñas?
Pequeñas.
De... de...
techo de paja
y pared de cinque.
De cinque. Estábamos teniendo cinque.
¿Y qué tenía? ¿Para dormir? ¿Y tenía baños?
Por favor.
Ya yo no quiero decir qué era.
Más peor que uno se puede presentar.
Bueno.
Descríbamelo, por favor.
Baños, cada uno hizo un piso.
Y en la mañana tenía que limpiar de contrapos, cada uno.
Su sitio.
Comida era,
si ustedes saben,
antiguas mujeres tenían, se llamaban,
para la noche, para adivinar,
bisnick.
Y en esto querían comer a todo el mundo.
Veganza. ¿Ustedes me entienden?
Más miserable que puede ser.
La gente de allá murieron como moscos.
¿De qué le daban de comer de desayuno?
¿De desayuno qué comía?
Era así.
Dos papas,
medio crudo,
con un...
zanahorio
y agua caliente.
¿Eso era desayuno?
Eso era desayuno.
¿Y almuerzo?
El almuerzo era
un café negro.
Nada más.
Eso era desayuno.
¿Y cena?
En las seis era más miserable que puede ser.
La gente se lo contaron.
¿Qué era de cena?
¿Cómo?
¿Qué comía de cena?
Eso igual que comieron.
¿No era otra cosa?
Las papas.
Mire, ¿usted sabe qué es hambre?
¿Entonces qué hacía? ¿Dormía? ¿Conseguía?
Yo...
te digo la verdad.
Este Krikov era
doce kilómetros de mi seredera.
Tenía que pasar un campo.
Yo era capaz de huir.
Pero mi señora no me dejó.
Y si Dios ayudó a nosotros
a salir del cemeterio,
Dios
va a ayudar
a salir de acá también.
Yo estuve en Krikov
de domingo la noche
hasta viernes a las nueve de la mañana.
¿En qué trabajó durante ese tiempo?
Nada.
Nosotros dos todos lloramos trabajo.
¿Por qué?
No sé.
Si me preguntan por qué,
no sé.
Puro,
inesto,
cuarto,
todo el tiempo
nos dieron
algo preso abajo,
abajo cabeza, algo en piso,
y al día y noche allá.
¿No trabajó en nada?
No, tenía un resto
saliendo allá.
Allá trajeron
ese comida que dijo usted.
¿Tenía contacto con otras personas?
Nada.
¿Por qué?
No puedo decir.
No sé.
¿Quién era?
¿Por qué?
Si era orden,
si no era orden,
no puedo contestar.
Ese polaco
que yo encontré sacando de la crematoria,
inmediatamente